we have the confidence now to say that
we can tell stories about one so I think
when you have a heritage jewel like this
it's important for us to make that
heritage relevant to today so that then
is not an extension of his life beyond
its history when we started working on
the project it was really you know
helping this great campus which is a
heritage building and trying to create
you know a hotel out of it there was the
brief from the client first thing we did
was really to do research on obviously
the historical and context of the
building and digging all the stories
absolutely all these bits of stories
were really juicy enough for us to then
start to think about how we should play
out you know this narrative for the
hotel so I think in terms of the lobby
is the biggest tribute where we had all
these green lights that were inspired
from the era where they used to hoist
all the goods so that you know the
stories are layered and rich
you kind of learn as you experience the
space again and again if you look into
all these details we have a lot of
collaboration with the local craftsmen
the designers so when you stay at the
hotel you really get a sense of this
authenticity and you get to know
Singapore a bit better we were my food
to make the lobby interesting place so
that the locals can come and interact
with the guests so it has energy to the
space and you feel that you're part of
the community around the space and
community whether it's the design the
art or you know music industry they can
use it as a place to launch new ideas so
that becomes a point where the energy of
that space can really develop and
compositions can take place so if you
look at the lobby space it was really
intended for all that to happen I was
very conscious of us to respect what was
there before and then from the stories
see how we can reinterpret it for the
future
you